they've seen a surge of people at this
covid testing site in the last week
300 a day in a state seeing
record-breaking case numbers
and how the politicians are handling the
pandemic is a national talking point
i think it's interesting to hear both
sides and i think there's pros and cons
to
the way different people are handling it
but it's
it's you know it is what it is at this
point it's a pandemic
it's really hard to tell what truth of
what's going on so
you make do with what you can i suppose
i i feel like
the economy needs to reopen um
people need to be able to work
just a mile from here is the debate
stage where the pandemic will once again
dominate plastic screen to separate the
two candidates is the most visible sign
of how the virus is
shaping america that the incumbent vice
president is also the head of the white
house response
and is a heartbeat away from a president
who's infected
makes it the issue for kamala harris
it's all about selling a different path
out of the pandemic and this is
happening a week after that first
shambolic presidential debate and real
questions about
if and how the next two presidential
debates can even take place
for so many reasons there will be extra
focus on what happens here tonight
at an uncertain time in america
at the boxing gym they work out those
frustrations america is a nutritional
place right now
everyone sees it and most of them are
sick of it in watching the presidential
debate
i was a little devoid of hope i'm a bit
more hopeful for the
vice presidential debate because they
feel like
they might actually be apt to listen to
each other as opposed to talking over
one another because that's not
debate that's yelling so i i'm hoping
that that will
show a little bit more like to the
american public who's capable of running
this i feel a lot of hate
and division and i it doesn't sit well
with me
i feel like we should um
love each other support each other more
and right now it i just it's like
hate on both sides there's just no
middle ground
it's kind of a scary world to live in
right now i think there's a lot of hate
from both sides but i think
one kind of instigates it and i don't
like seeing that
that is the mood as a divide in america
tunes into another debate
and very few have any faith they'll get
the answers they want to hear